قالت المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه النتاليا هونيويورك ان الجيش
الاوكرانيه بدا ما سمتها عمليه تطهير
للشريط الامامي للضفه الشرقيه من نهر
دنيفر في مقاطعه خرسون الجنوبيه البلاد
واضافت في تصريحات للتلفزيون الرسمي ان
الجيش وجه ضربات مكثفه لمواقع الروس في
خرسون خلال الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
واشارت الى ان عمليات الجيش في خرسون
تتطلب صمتا اعلاميا حتى يصبح الوضع امنا
بدرجه كافيه
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه تقوم بتطهير
الضفه الشرقيه من نهر دنيبر في خيرسون حيث
يوجد الغزاه الروس وجهنا خلال الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه ضربات قويه للقوات
الروسيه هناك وفي عموم الجنوب يجب ان نعطي
العسكريين الفرصه الكامله لاداء عملهم
بهدوء ظروف العمليه العسكريه الحاليه
تتطلب الصمت حتى يصبح الوضع امنا بدرجه
كافيه للجيش الاوكراني
انضم الينا من مراسل الجزيره تامر الصمادي
تامر يعني هناك حاله من الصمت ربما تعتيم
على هذه العمليه وتفاصيلها لكن ما الذي
نعرفه حتى الان عم وصف اوكرانيا بعمليه
تطهير واسعه للضفه الشرقيه لنهر
كما قلنا في المباشره السابق نحن امام
عمليه كاسحه واسعه منسقه منظمه للقوات
الاوكرانيه في جنوب جنوب البلاد وتحديدا
في خيرسون وهو ما اشاره اليه بشكل واضح
وذلك استنادا بالتاكيد ما سبق لقياده
عمليات الجنوب وهو ما شارت اليه المتحدثه
باسم القياده الجنوبيه قالت بان عمليه
تطهير بدات بالفعل للشريط الامامي
لنهر دينيبر في خرسون الحديث عن الضفه
الشرقيه اليسرى التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه منذ انسحابها اواخر العام الماضي
من مدينه
خيرسون الحديث عن نتائج قويه كما قالت على
المتحدثه الاوكرانيه على التلفزيون الرسمي
الاوكراني وتقول بان الايام الثلاثه
الماضيه شهدت ايضا ضربات قويه مكثفه على
الواقع تركز القوات الروسيه هناك تقول
ايضا بان الضفه الشرقيه بالكامل بالكامل
تحت وابل القصف الاوكراني المستمر والحديث
عن
مسانده من قبل المنظومات الصاروخيه
الاوكرانيه الحديث ايضا عن مدفعيه
اوكرانيه المتحدثه الاوكرانيه تقول بان
اكثر من 13 الى عشرين عتادا عسكريا روسيا
ثقيلا يتم تدميره بشكل يومي من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تستهدف مواقع الروس في
خرسون يعني لم تشهر المتحدثه باسم قياده
عمليات الجنوب الى الهجوم المضاد لم ياتي
على لسانها هذا الوصف وذلك قد يكون امرا
مبررا في ظل حاله التكتم الشديد التي
يفرضها
الواقع الاوكراني هنالك حاله من التكتم من
السريه
التي يشير اليها
المسؤولون او يتعامل معها العديد من
المسؤولين السياسيين والعسكريين
الاوكرانيين فيما يخص الهجوم المضاد لا
سيما مع التسريبات التي حدثت اخيرا لوثائق
امريكيه في الولايات المتحده كانت تتحدث
عن هذا الهجوم طيله الفتره الماضيه كان
الحديث يجري عن هجوم مضاد في الربيع في
الصيف ونحن حاليا في الربيع وبعد تلك
التسريبات جرى قرار او صدر قرار بالتكتم
على هذا الهجوم لكن كل المؤشرات كما قلنا
سابقا تدلل على ان الهجوم المضاد بدا
بالفعل من خرسون هذه المره شكرا جزيلا لك
تامر صمادي مراسله